Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Zwei Spieltage sind es nur noch in der 2. Männer-Bundesliga und es ist schon wieder so einiges passiert. Wir blicken auf die Liga heute mal einmal mit dem oberen Segment und einmal mit dem unteren Segment. Hallo und herzlich Willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Hier ist der Rasenfunk Kurzpass Nummer 265 und wir werden heute sprechen über die 2. Männer-Bundesliga. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost, ich bin der Ed Genetzer auf mastodon.social und ich freue mich sehr, zwei Gäste hier zu haben. Zum einen Nando Silva vom HSV-Podcast Volkspark Geflüster, einer der Podcasts, die sich in der großen Podcast HSV-Schwemme damals gegründet haben, der aber immer noch sendet. Das muss man wirklich sagen. Das war wirklich verrückt. Da gab es so eine Zeit, da musste ich bei jedem Update der Podcastshow einen neuen HSV-Podcast eintragen.
Orientiert euch einfach an der Leistung des Jan-Blogs. Dann klappt das auch auf jeden Fall mit dem Wiederaufstieg. Was ist denn jetzt dein Gefühl gegenüber Tobias Werner, der ja als Geschäftsführersport jetzt an der entscheidenden Stelle sitzt und ja auch in große Fußstapfen tritt? Ihr hattet ja auch die Möglichkeit, mit ihm zu sprechen, glaube ich.
Ich glaube, eine Woche später hat er ihn dann entlassen. Also er oder Utham.
Herzlich willkommen beim Sportjournalismus.
Und ein Bild von ihm, ja, ich weiß nicht recht eigentlich, was ich von ihm halten soll, weil in Jena, was man sich hört, waren sie jetzt am Ende auch nicht mehr so 100% überzeugt. Da denke ich mir, ja, ich habe mit Roger Stülz jemanden, ja, das hat einfach nicht gepasst, einfach hinten und vorne nicht. Das war ein reines Chaos am Ende. Und dann, dass man wieder so einen Unerfahren hat. Da weiß ich halt nicht, ob das so gut für Renes vor allem in dieser Lage ist. Aber er muss sich in der Öffentlichkeit offensiver positionieren. Man hört eigentlich gar nichts von ihm außer halt bei uns Fan-Medien. Aber das ist halt, wie soll ich sagen, für die breite Jahngemeinde halt dann auch zu wenig. Da muss ich eine größere Medien mal positionieren. Man hört nur sehr vereinzete Sachen und halt auch viel zu allgemein. Ich meine, wenn ich die Vertragsverlängerungen höre zum Beispiel, dann heißt es ja, mir bin ich im Rat ein Kapitän im Vertrag vor Ligen. Aber der unterschreibt einfach nicht. Und Christian Kaller hätte jetzt gesagt, ja, entweder du unterschreibst jetzt in drei Wochen oder du kannst schauen, wo du bleibst. Und das macht halt Tobi Werner jetzt. Ich weiß es nicht, aber ich kann es mir vorstellen, weil ich ihm so einen Pikan so nach und ab wahrnehme, wirkt es halt sehr unerfahren. Und das ist nämlich zu verübeln. Er kann auch nichts dafür. Es ist eine riesen Chance für ihn. Er muss lernen, er muss sehr gezahlen. Das hat mir wagt, er nicht. Und ich denke, er kann es definitiv, aber er muss jetzt auch mal zeigen, dass er es kann.
Nicht mal Lehrgeld hat er, Jan. Meine Güte, das sind ja sämtliche Kassen leer. Und gleichzeitig sind ja damals mit Christian Keller auch die Chefscouts zum 1. FC Köln gewechselt. Das kommt ja noch mit dazu. Also, weil bisher ist man ja dadurch aufgefallen, dass man bessere Transfers gemacht hat als mancher Konkurrent und deswegen auch quasi mit geringerem finanziellen Einsatz eben sich in der 2. Liga erhalten konnte. Das ist ein weiterer Aspekt.
Ja, genau, das ist auch unser Punkt. Bisher hört man noch nichts, dass neue Scouts da wären. Das macht mir auch ein bisschen Angst für die kommende Transferphase, mal ich sagen. Ich weiß nicht, ich glaube, mit Robert hat er mal ein längeres Interview geführt. Das ist auch schon 2 Monate her und da hat er gesagt, ja, ihr habt zwar Namen auf der Liste, aber ihr habt noch niemanden gefunden. Das ist jetzt nicht so viel Versprechen für die kommende Saison. Wir müssen gut skaten, wir müssen finden, was sonst niemand findet und das macht schon Sorge, wenn man dann die Scouts nicht hat dafür. Da ist schon ein Qualitätsverlust da, weil wir hatten schon enorm gute Scouts, auch wenn jetzt die letzte Transferphase nicht optimal war. Aber trotzdem fehlt da jetzt ein Puzzletal mehr, was eh schon fehlt mit Köln. Wir müssen schauen, dass wir das in die Tür setzen, auch wenn es schwer wird. Das ist eine nächste Mammutsaufgabe für die Zukunft und wird auch spannend.
Okay, apropos spannend. Dann lasst doch jetzt auch noch das machen, was wir für den Aufstieg gemacht haben, mit dem Abstiegskampf. Lasst doch da jetzt auch nochmal draufblicken und dann sagt ihr uns einfach, wie es läuft. Weil dann ist es ein bisschen weniger spannend für uns, die wir einfach nur so neutral auf die Liga gucken. Also der SV Sandhausen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, gegen wen spielt der? Wenn ihr aufgepasst habt, dann wisst ihr das vielleicht schon. Na ja, ich sage es trotzdem nochmal. Sandhausen spielt auswärts in Heidenheim zu Hause gegen den HSV. Sandhausen hat 5 Punkte Rückstand auf Bielefeld und es ist schon nicht mehr zu schaffen, auf einen Nicht-Abstiegsplatz zu springen. Max, was ist dein Gefühl? Holt der SVS da noch etwas?
Entweder Platz 17 oder Platz 18, was ja auch mit der Lizenz von Hertha bewegend werden könnte. Ich glaube zwar nicht, aber theoretisch wäre das noch mal wichtig.
Ach so, wenn Hertha absteigt und dann keine Lizenz bekäme. Das sind ja Gedankenspiele, die hatte ich noch gar nicht.
Das gab es 2012 und 2013 schon mal mit Duisburg. Da wurde der Jan 18. und dann sind wir natürlich abgestiegen. Typisch Jan eigentlich. Ich befürchte, dass es diesmal auch so wird, aber ich glaube, es ändert sich nichts mehr. Ich glaube, Sandhausen bleibt auf 18 und der Jan leider auf 17.
Das heißt, jetzt dann in Braunschweig und dann am Schluss mit dem großen Holtrio gegen Heidenheim erwartest du keine großen Sprünge mehr?
Ja, wenn ich die Mannschaft so sehe, leider nicht. Ich glaube, jeder will einfach dieses so abschließen. Ich glaube, es geht leider nichts mehr.
Okay, dann wird es jetzt interessant, Nando. Da interessiert mich auch deine Meinung. Bielefeld spielt gegen Paderborn und in Magdeburg, hat 33 Punkte. Der 1. FC Nürnberg spielt gegen Hansa Rostock zu Hause und dann in Paderborn, die haben 35 Punkte. Und Eintracht Braunschweig spielt zu Hause gegen den Jan und dann in Rostock, die haben 36 Punkte. Wahrscheinlich wird es sich zwischen diesen Teams entscheiden, wer dann die Relegation spielt. Nando, was erwartest du?
Das sind harte Fights. Rostock hat es ja so ein bisschen in der eigenen Hand.
Rostock habe ich jetzt schon rausgerechnet, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich glaube, die haben auch so eine Mentalität, die können das. Die Frage ist, holt Bielefeld diese zwei Punkte auf Nürnberg auf mit dem besseren Torverhältnis? Ich glaube es nicht. Ich glaube, Nürnberg holt irgendwie die zwei Punkte, die sie brauchen, und mehr, und können diesen Vorsprung halten vor Bielefeld, weil ich bei Bielefeld in dieser Saison des Öfteren gedacht habe, jetzt haben sie es, jetzt haben sie die Kurve bekommen, und dann ging es wieder steil bergab, und da muss auch irgendetwas kaputtgegangen sein, was irgendwie irreparabel scheint in dieser Saison. Das ist so gespickt mit tollen Spielern, und es funktioniert nicht. Deswegen glaube ich, dass Bielefeld in ihre Legation muss.
Schwierig, schwierig. Bielefeld oder Nürnberg? Zwei Clubs, die darfst du eigentlich nicht sehen auf diesem Platz. Ich glaube es ähnlich wie Nando. Ich glaube, Nürnberg holt noch. Ich muss jetzt nichts mehr holen. Aber ich sehe seit mal nicht, dass Bielefeld noch viel holt. Da wirkt einfach wirklich etwas kaputt. Keine Ahnung. Letztes Jahr noch Bundesliga, und jetzt auf einmal das. Das ist schon überraschend. Das tut dann, so was der Fäne auch immer nicht. Was ist denn da los? Also keine Ahnung. Und ich dachte lange Zeit, die werden sich noch irgendwie raus retten, wie man es oft bei solchen Teams denkt. Aber nein, die stehen da unten drin. Und ich glaube, die müssen wirklich in ihre Integration. Was natürlich auch immer schwierig ist, weil die Leistungsdichte ist ja doch noch ziemlich niedrig zur 3. Liga. Und dann kommen die aus der 3. Liga mit einem Schwung. Und dann wird halt das auch brutal schwierig. Die müssen echt schauen, dass sie da nicht nochmal rutschen. Weil das wäre wahrscheinlich für den Verein schon ein harter Schlag.
Und Braunschweig rechnet ihr beide schon raus mit ihren 36 Punkten. Sind ja rein theoretisch auch nur 3 Punkte vom Relegationsplatz weg.
Ja, also Braunschweig glaube ich einfach. Die wirken so. Die haben diese Aufsteigermentalität. Die werden jetzt kämpfen bis zum Ende, glaube ich. Die haben ja sogar einen Fangesang dazu. Und ich glaube einfach, die hat mit auch mit Fera einen unglaublichen Spieler. Also von ihm halte ich unglaublich viel ein. Muss ich noch ergänzen. Und ich glaube einfach, die paar uns einfach.
Die spielen ja jetzt auch als nächstes gegen den Jagen. Sorry.
Ja, das sind dann die 3 Punkte zum Gassen.
Genau, genau. Ich muss sagen, ich bin natürlich der mit am weitesten wenigsten Ahnung hier in der Runde. Ich wurde und gleichzeitig wurde ich sozialisiert mit der Club Sadeb. Ich komme ja genau aus der Region, wo alle Clubfans sind. Das schreit alles so dermaßen danach, dass Bielefeld das Derby gewinnt und Nürnberg gegen Rostock maximalen Punkt holt. Und dann stehen die beide bei 36 oder vielleicht sogar der Club bei 35. Und dann zittern die beide aber so dermaßen in Paderborn und in Magdeburg am 34. Spieltag. Und dann macht es das Team, das einfach mehr Glück hat, so wie es halt dann ist. Mich hat positiver überrascht in dieser Saison häufiger Bielefeld. Ich habe Bielefeld schon häufiger weggesehen. Und sie haben es aber dann immer mal wieder geschafft. War das nicht in Regensburg auch so, wo dann auch Kloss getroffen hat? Ja, genau.
Kloss hat dann kurz vor Schluss an den Ballen in der Ecke geköpft. Das war auch so ein Schlag für uns. Das hat auch richtig wehgetan. Ich dachte eigentlich, das verleiht ihnen einen richtigen Aufschwung. Ich glaube, Darmstadt haben sie auch geschlagen. Und du denkst, das muss doch der Mannschaft den Job geben. Aber nein, nicht.
Das ist auch mein Problem mit Bielefeld tatsächlich aktuell.
Ja, aber andererseits. Sie haben das schon mal geschafft. Ich habe vorher noch mit Eva über ihre Auswärtsbilanz gesprochen, der Arminia. Man liegt mit 0 zu 1 in der zweiten Minute zurück. Und dann Ausgleich in der 14. Minute, in der 85. Minute, 1 zu 2 aus Sicht der Regensburger und dann in der 91. 1 zu 3. Und dann war es das. Deswegen sehe ich Nürnberg eher in noch größerer Gefahr als Bielefeld. Letztlich kann es keiner von uns wissen. Das ist wie Vuskovic, nur auf einer anderen Ebene. Ja, ihr zwei, ich danke euch sehr für diese Einblicke in eure Vereine. Das waren zwei sehr unterschiedliche Segmente. Und doch irgendwie gab es so viele Parallelen, dass ich mir aus beiden Vereinssicht ein bisschen Sorgen machen würde. Also ich hatte zwischendurch auch das Gefühl, Nando, ich weiß nicht, ob ich da jetzt zu negativ gebiased bin aus den letzten Jahren, aber ich habe auch so das Gefühl, der sportliche Erfolg ist gerade das, was beim HSV den Deckel auf dem Kochtopf hält und drunter brodelt eigentlich schon wieder die ganze Zeit. Aber wir reden halt nicht drüber.
Man weiß halt nicht, was passiert, wenn. Also was passiert nach der Saison, wenn man das Saisonziel nicht erreicht. Das ist ja eine offene Diskussion und die Strömungen im Verein. Man kann es sehr schwer einschätzen, ob dann erneut Gegenwind kommt, ob dann tatsächlich auch nicht nur Tim Walther, sondern auch Jonas Beutzig eben dem verfehlten Saisonziel stellen müssen, das Konsequenzen haben kann, was vielleicht sogar auch gerechtfertigt wäre. Diese offene Diskussion muss es ja am Ende der Saison geben, ob Aufstieg oder eben nicht. Musst du dich ja für die nächste Saison neu aufstellen oder das Ganze auch so analysieren, dass du eben noch konstanterer wirst. Wenn du aufsteigst, hast du ganz andere Anforderungen. Aber eben in der 2. Liga irgendwann kannst du solche Spieler einfach auf Dauer nicht bezahlen. Irgendwann kannst du nicht mehr so viel Transferlös generieren, dass du gute Spieler auch mit einem vernünftigen Gehalt bezahlen kannst. Das sind alles Sachen. Natürlich, je nach Saisonergebnis kann das auch in Hamburg nochmal zu medial begleitetem und natürlich auch emotionaler Fan-Begleitung zu großen Themen kommen. Wir wissen alle, in Hamburg spricht man auch gerne mit den Medien, auch wenn man es nicht sollte an der einen oder anderen Stelle. Dann kann genau das passieren, was du sagst.
Dann geht es wieder genauso weiter wie immer. Ich muss sagen, das ist jetzt ganz subjektiv und das ist überhaupt nichts gegen die anderen Vereine. Aber ich habe so krass Bock, wieder mit dem HSV, über den HSV in der Schlusskonferenz zu reden. Wahrscheinlich bereue ich es schon an Spieltag 3, wo ich dann irgendwie wieder böse Tweets bekomme, weil ich einen Witz zu viel gemacht habe. Dafür entschuldige ich mich jetzt schon. Aber es ist einfach wieder Zeit. Der HSV ist Teil des Rasenfunks, so wie Darmstadt ehrlicherweise auch. Die waren ja auch schon in der 1. Liga, als wir hier waren. Also irgendwie, ja, also... Das hätte man dem HSV doch mal sagen müssen, dass sie in die Schlusskonferenz kommen. Mensch, wahrscheinlich wird es dann... Herr Walther, wie haben Sie es geschafft, am 34. Spieltag die Mannschaft zu motivieren? Und dann hatte er halt einfach nur das hier eingespielt. Und dann wussten sie, okay, wir haben so richtig Bock. Wie schön noch, dass ich das Autor anstelle des Intros eingespielt habe. Aber dem Walther wusste er einfach nicht so genau, was er da tun soll. Aber für das Outro muss ich mich ja erst noch ordentlich von euch verabschieden. Ganz herzlichen Dank an Nando Silva, der Ed F. Santos Silva auf Twitter vom Volkspark geflüstert. Sehr empfehlenswerter HSV-Podcast. Auf Twitter auch unterwegs als HSV-Podcast. Erst schon mal gut diesen Händel bekommen zu haben. Ist es der Unterstrich, der ist richtig, ne? Genau. Also, vielen Dank, Nando, dass du hier mit dabei warst. Ich freue mich auf die Erstligaschlusskonferenzen mit dir.
Ja, vielen lieben Dank für die Einloggen. Ganz groß, war richtig toll hier. Und vor allen Dingen mit Max war das großartig. Also mit dem jungen Max. Aber absolut. Solche Eindrücke zu bekommen, grandios.
Aber echt, ey, mit 16 Jahren kann der hier im Podcast einfach, ist in der Mixed Zone und analysiert das alles durch. Und so, ich hab mit, also ich war mit 16 froh, wenn ich meine Hose richtig rumanröte. Naja, also, Max Aichinger von der Jahnblog.de. Ich werde natürlich alles verlinken. Danke dir, lieber Max, dass du hier warst. Ja, bis zum nächsten Mal. Ich drücke den Vereinen von euch beiden alle Daumen und bedanke mich bei euch auch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörern. Jetzt hören wir nochmal das Outro. Aber jetzt ist es auch wirklich so. Jetzt muss ich euch Tschüss sagen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Das war Rasenfunk Kurzpass Nummer 265. Bleibt uns gewogen. Es gibt genügend Themen. Es gibt genügend Dinge, die man im Rasenfunk hören kann. Geht einfach mal auf rasenfunk.de, da erfahrt ihr das. Und übrigens der Rasenfunk Royale. Da gibt's jetzt auch die Threads schon im Forum unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de. Ist ja vielleicht auch für euch interessant. Macht's gut, bis bald, hier wieder im Rasenfunk.